[音楽]
bl
th
みなさんこんにちはそろそろお腹空いてきていませんか
私のトークの後でランチタイムに入ると思うのでもう少しだけお付き合いいただければ
と思います本日は私なりの暮らし方の光復路についてお伝えしたいと思います
今会場にいる皆さんの中で毎日ハッピー幸せに暮らしていますという人はどれ位
いらっしゃいますか
お素晴らしい今どうぞと手を上げられた方は良かったらぜひ後でお友達になって
ください
私はですね数年前にうつ病を経験しております
その時の経験から自分をどういう幸福な状態に置いておけばその病気を繰り返さずに
すむんだろうということをとてもよく考えます私の今の人生の目標は私が死ぬ時に
なんていい人生だったんだ
ろうと思って死んでいくことです
今日の私のスピーチを通して自分の人生が幸せかどうかよくわからない
そもそもそんなことを考えたこともないという人が何かを考えるきっかけになってくれ
たら嬉しいです
さて人が駅ていく中で必要な要素としていい食住というものがあります私たちは何を
着ればテンションが上がって何を食べれば幸せな気分になるかというのは人生の中で
学んで来ると思いますが
では最後の住まいについてはどうでしょうか
こういう家に
夢たら幸せだなというイメージはありますか
例えばプールが付いている大豪邸だったりリビングにたんろがあるような立派な家だっ
たり
でもどうでしょうプールや暖炉があるだけで本当に幸せだと言えるんでしょうか
プールに水を張って泳いでいても自分一人だけ
暖炉の火を見つめるのもたった1人ぼっちだったらそれこそサビ
しすぎてうつ病になってしまうかもしれません私は相撲の幸せというのはそうした物理
的なものとは別の部分にあると考えてい
突然ですが
私には5つの家があります
a 棟
普通の28歳の日本の女性からするとかなりリッチな暮らし
これこそ物理的じゃないかな暮らしをしているんですけれども
そのどれもが古さを生かしたリノベーションをしていて
みんなでウッドデッキを作って完成パーティーをしたり
お庭が付いているような家もあります
夏には浴衣を着て集まってパーティーをしたり
秋には地域の子どもたちを集めてハロウィンパーティーをしたりしました
これは今私の暮らしかたをサンプルにお話をしています
こうしたたのしい家が私には居つつもありますそしてその中には家賃がなんと0円
ただの家もあります
どうして私がこんな生活をできているのでしょうか
それは
私の仕事がシェアハウスマネージャーだからです
まるで全て自分の家であるかのように言ってしまいましたが
それぞれの家のオーナーさんから管理を任されてそこをシェアハウスとして運営してい
ます
シェアハウスって一体何だろうという方ももしかしたらいらっしゃるかもしれないので
簡単に説明をさせていただきます
シェアハウスはこの間取りを見ていただくと分かるようにオレンジ色の部分
リビングやキッチン水色の部分のバスルームやトイレなどをシェアして使う
ライフスタイルのことです平和各自に分けられていることが多いです
日本では2000年ごろからシェアハウスの物件が増えてきて今でも右肩上がりに物件
数が増えています
普通に家を借りるよりも低コストで新しい生活を始めることができるという経済的な
部分に注目されている面がありますが私はシェアハウスが日本で今増えているのは
もっと別な理由もあると考えていますシェアハウスは現代の日本に求められている
暮らし方だと思っています
まず私がシェアハウスを始めたきっかけをお伝えさせてください
私がシェアハウスを始めたのは今から2年前私が26歳の時のことです
私は1年間のうつ病機関から立ち直ったばっかりで自分のライフプランを真剣に考え
直していました
私がうつ病になってしまった原因はいろいろありますが大きくはライフワークバランス
を崩してしまったからです
私は時間の余裕もあってお金の余裕もあるビジネスをしようと考えました
でも時間をかけずにお金を埋める仕事っていったいなんだろうと考えた時に私の祖母の
言葉を思い出します
私の祖母は自宅の1階を賃貸住宅にリフォームをしてお部屋を貸す仕事をしていました
祖母は私に言いますおばあちゃんがおばあちゃんになってもいい生活ができるのは家賃
が入ってくるからなんだよと
私はこれだと思い賃貸経営の勉強を始めました
しかし私の最終学歴は高卒です
正社員の経験もありませんでしたまともな貯金もないそんな人が銀行に行って不動産
経営をしたいのでお金を貸してくださいと言ってもまともにお金を出してくれるような
銀行はありません
どうしたらいいんだろうと思っていた時に仙台に行ってくる
留学生が部屋探しに困っているという話を聞きました
であれば私が彼らの代わりに部屋を借りて彼らにシェアハウスとして済んでもらえれば
私には家賃が入ってくる
彼らは部屋探しに困らないみんながハッピーになるビジネスじゃないかということで
シェアハウスビジネスをスタートさせます
これは私が一番最初にシェアハウス用の物件をゲットしたときの写真です
まるで愛しいは各を出産できたような気分でした
これから宜しくねーというふうに柱を叩き締めている写真です
なぜこんなに喜んでいるかと言うと仙台でシェアハウス用の物件を探すことはとても
大変だったんです
不動産会社の人たちは私に言います
外国人なんて部屋を重ね方がいいよ
なんか彼らはトラブルの原因になるんだそうです
あとをシェアハウスという言葉もあまりイメージがなかったようです
若い人たちが集まって暮らすので騒いで近所迷惑になるというイメージがあったのかも
しれません
それで私はメディずにシェアハウスと外国人という不動産業界の2大タブーを突き進ん
できたわけです
そうして私に待っていたのはトラブルに追われる
大変な日々ではなく刺激的で面白い毎日でした私はシェアハウスに住みながらにして
世界中を旅しているよう
な気分でしたインドの本場のカレーの味やフィンランドの知ってますかねリコリス天
ものすごい味であったり
分かりますかアメリカのタコスの味などですそれらはお店で買って食べるよりも私の
記憶の中に鮮明に残っています
シェアハウスでレア人たちもこれは日本人外国人問わずとても面白い人たちばかりでし
た
そもそもシェアハウスという生活を選んでいる時点で彼らは場所や物にとらわれない
生き方をしています
いいものを買ったりいい服を着たりということよりも
誰かとコミュニケーションしたり何か素敵な体験を
いることに豊かさを見出している人が多いです
こちらの図をご覧くださいこれは心理学者のアブラハムマズロー氏が提唱している
人間の欲求五段階の頭です人間の欲求はピラミッドのようにできていて一番下の段が
満たされるとより次の段罪土壇と求めていくという図です
一番下の生理的欲求はね
たい食べタイ飲みタイなどの本能的な欲求です
その次に安全の欲求安心安全な暮らしを得たいと思います
その次に所属欲求仲間や集団に所属したくなります次に承認の欲求その中で尊敬され
たり認められたくなります
最後に自己実現の欲求自分のスキルを活かしてクリエイティブなことをやっていきたく
なります
シェアハウスに住んでいる人は基本的にこの下から3段分を満たしている人が多いです
生理的欲求は自分で満たす必要がありますが
安心安全で株価でもついている家に低コストで済むことができます
また住んでいるだけでシェアハウスの中のコミュニティに所属することもできます
ではシェアハウス以外の現代の暮らし方はどうでしょうか
私たちは簡単に孤立をする社会の中で生きています
仕事と家の往復だけの忙しい毎日
隣の部屋に誰が住んでいるか分かる人はいらっしゃいますでしょうか
は多種多様なバックグラウンドを持つ人と交流する機会が少なかったり
会社や学校といったコミュニティに馴染めないと孤立感を感じてしまいます
孤立であることの何が問題なのでしょうか
驚くべき研究結果が出ています
脳神経学研究者のマシューリバンマン博士の調査によると
人が肉体的な痛みを負った時と孤独感を感じた時とでその痛みを処理するために活性化
する脳の部分が同じであるということが研究されています
孤独感を感じることは私たちの脳は
=痛みであるというふうに感じるのです
こうした問題はシェアハウスに住むことで解決します
家に帰ってくるとおかえりと言ってくれる人がいます
隣の部屋にはもちろん誰が住んでいるのか分かっていますし私のようにいろいろな国籍
の人たち
色々な考え方の人たちと出会うきっかけもあります
またもしシェアハウスの人と馬が合わなければ
かバニー往復だけ詰め込んですぐに別のシェアハウスへ引っ越すこともできます
これはものに囚われない暮らしだからこそができることです
しかしじゃあ誰もがシェアハウスに明日から住んでみましょうというわけにはいかない
と思います
このイラストは一例でこういったシェアハウスで生活をしていなくとも幸せに生活をし
ている人はいると思います
ではどうして私たちの社会はこのように孤立しやすい社会になってしまったのでしょう
か
私は過去の歴史を振り返ってみました
今から60年以上前第二次世界大戦前の日本です
そこには村と呼ばれるコミュニティがあり人は農業を営みながら生活をしていました
村の中にはいえというコミュニティがあります家ではお父さんがリーダーです
リーダーは代々長男に引き継がれていってそして家計やお墓を守っていました
しかしこのコミュニティの問題点はお父さんがリーダーであるがゆえに
お父さんに逆らったら感動する度と言われたりとは長男以外の子供の立場や女性の立場
が弱かったことです
現代で言うパワハラや村原
dv などが当たり前のように行われてい
誰かもしれません
そして私たちは終戦を迎えて戦後の日本に入ると
高度経済成長期に入りとかいや工場に出て働く人が増えてきました
欧米的な思想が入ってきたのでお見合い結婚から恋愛結婚してそれぞれが家庭を持つ
ようになりました
とても良い生活に見えますがこの暮らし方にも問題点が生じてきています
今までムラ社会の中で行っていた子育てや介護を夫婦二人でほとんど奥さんですね
奥さんだけでやらなくてはいけなくなったことバブルが崩壊したので旦那さんだけの
稼ぎで家庭をやりくりしていくことが難しくなりました
田舎に取り残された高齢者がポリ尽かしてしまうという問題もあります
現代の日本では素敵な人と恋愛をして結婚をして家庭を持つことが人生の成功であると
いうふうに言われています
しかしそれは本当にいまの私たちのライフスタイルに合っているんでしょうか
こうした考え方はたった60年前
私たちのお父さんやお母さんの時代に始まった生き方です
私が外国人に部屋を貸すのは辞めたほうがいいと言われても成功できたように多くの人
がそう言っているからといってそれが正しい道であるとは限らないのです
それでは最後になりますがこれまでの問題点と現代の問題点を踏まえた上で私なりに
幸せ暮らし方の幸福論というものを3つにまとめてみました
まず一つ目は衣食住の不安がないことです
これは本当にベーシックな最低限の事ですね
二つ目は個人の自由があることですこれは私たちは村社会の時代に学びました
家やしきたりにとらわれず自分自身で自分の人生を選択して生きていくことができる
社会を望みました
3つ目は家族以外の繋がりを持つことです
これは村社会を飛び出して核家族として生活する中で家族だけのコミュニティでは手が
足りないことがあったり
今た
家族とはいえいえ家族だからこそ
相性が合わないということもあります
家族以外の心が許せるコミュニティを持っているということは私たちの人生を安らかに
してくれます
これは私の毎日の写真ですが学校や会社
家族といったコミュニティ以外にもっと緩くフラットにつながれるコミュニティが現代
の日本社会では求められています
幸せの形というのも人それぞれ多様化してきました
昔はずっと独身でいるだけでまた離婚をしただけで白い目で見られるような社会でした
が時代とともにそういった風潮も薄れてきています
こうした暮らし方をすれば誰もが幸せになれるという間プレートは今の時代にはもう
存在しないということに気づいてください
私がシェアハウス生活を通してたくさんの人と出会ってきたようにさまざまな考え方や
価値観をみなさんには知っていただきたいです
今日の鉄塔 x もみなさんにとってとてもいい機会になると思います
そして目の前にあるさまざまな選択肢の中から自分の状況に合ったものを選択して自由
に
クリエイトしていくあなたなりの幸福論を作るきっかけになっていただけたらとても
嬉しいです
最後までご清聴いただいてありがとうございました
[拍手]